[Music]
hello today we are going to learn how to
create a google compute engine virtual
machine instance
you can create a vm using the google
cloud console
the google cloud cli
the google cloud platform api
or client libraries in languages such as
c sharp go and java first start with
visiting the vm instances page in the
compute engine section here click on the
create instance button
before we proceed further decide how you
would like to create the instance
that is you could choose to create the
new instance from scratch
using an existing template
a machine image or a ready-to-go
solution from google cloud platform
marketplace
for now we'll create an instance from
scratch
next specify a name for your vm
here are some naming convention
guidelines that you need to follow
the name should be 1 to 63 characters in
length
it must always start with the lowercase
letter and then it can be followed by a
combination of hyphens lowercase letters
and numbers
it should not end with a hyphen we'll
use the name test hyphen instance 1.
now we'll add a label to the instance
labels help you group instances related
to a particular task together
if you would like to group this instance
add a key and a value attached to it
we will add the label as usage
test
as this is a test vm for us
now choose a region and zone for the vm
note
region and zone for a vm are permanent
configurations and cannot be changed
after a vm starts
let's create the instance in us hyphen
central 1 region and u.s hyphen central
one hyphen a zone decide the machine
configuration for your vm based on your
requirements you could choose from one
of these options
general purpose compute optimized memory
optimized and gpu based machines
let's choose the general purpose e2
machine
now select the machine series machine
type
number of cpus cpu platform amount of
ram and machine gpus
we'll choose an e2 hyphen medium type
machine with two vcbus and 4gb memory
the cpu would be automatically selected
and we will not be adding a gpu to this
instance
next if you wish to capture or record
this vm's screen then check the option
enable display device on the machine
we won't be enabling this because we
don't have a requirement of screen
recording this vm if you want to deploy
a container on this instance you could
walk through the container configuration
settings for the instance
for now we aren't deploying a container
on this instance so we'll skip this
in the boot disk section you need to
select the type and size of the instance
note the default configuration is a
debian image with 10 gb per system disk
you can replace this with public images
custom images snapshots or existing
disks
for this demonstration we will use the
standard debian gnu linux 11 image with
a 10gb persistent disk if you want your
applications to invoke google cloud
platform apis then you need to select a
service account in the identity and api
access section
choose a service account that has the
required level of api access
we will use a default compute engine
service account with default type
and level of api access to grant to the
vm
now let's move to the firewall section
if you want to allow http or https
traffic for your instance then enable
the allow http traffic and allow https
traffic setting check boxes
for our instance we prefer to enable
both these options finally we are done
with specifying all configurations for
our vm instance
review the monthly estimate for the vm
with the breakdown of items being used
and sustained use discounts applied if
you are happy then click the create
button and start the vm
congratulations the vm has been created
and is ready to use for more information
about creating vms please refer to our
official documentation
[Music]
you